la tour m de la cité du tennis c'est là
qu'une adolescente a été blessée par
balles le 19 février dernier et ses lacs
habitants et élus étaient appelés à se
rassembler pour faire front tous les
gens qui sont là ils sont là dans le
même dès que moi parce qu'ils sont
impliqués qu'ils sont dépassés par les
événements et consent pas protégés et
pas en tranquillité dans nos immeubles
vous avez peur oui oui ben beaucoup même
même beaucoup mais aujourd'hui on est
tous ensemble c'est bien tous concernés
tous solidaires derrière la même
bannière pour marcher jusqu'à torcy à
moins de deux kilomètres où un jeune
homme a été tué et un autre blessé
samedi dernier dans un règlement de
comptes ce qui se passe at war succès
pour savoir si la semaine d'ailleurs je
pense que la cap a été dépassé il
faudrait faudrait arrêter tout ça c'est
très important que nous puissions nous
montrer aussi unis aussi rassembler les
élus tous les élus du territoire les
parlementaires et bien entendu la
population unie et déterminée pour
demander plus de sécurité les nerfs de
torcy et du creusot attendent clairement
un geste de l'état messages reçus pour
rémy rebeyrotte députés de la majorité à
leurs côtés dans le cortège on est en
train les uns des autres de travailler à
renforcer les dispositifs de sécurité
il ya déjà beaucoup de choses qui se
font ici naturellement il faut qu'il y
ait un peu plus de moyens sans doute un
peu plus de coordination également c'est
tout le travail qui est engagée
la marche s'est achevée devant l'hôtel
de ville de torcy une marche symbolique
et le même souhait pour tous deux les
quartiers puisse enfin retrouver leur
tranquillité